All right, let's get into a
pretty gripping story.
It's all about friendship and
sheer desperation.
Set in a city that's just
drenched in darkness, this is
the story of trying to outrun
hell itself.
So our story kicks off not at
the beginning, but right in the
middle of total chaos.
A desperate rescue mission at a
public execution has just gone
completely sideways, leaving our
heroes scattered and in some
serious, serious danger.
I mean, they've lost a friend.
Two of the rescuers are
unconscious, and now they're
being hunted by the city's brand
new, ruthless leader.
The situation isn't just bad, it
is bleak.
And that's really the question
at the heart of all this, isn't
it?
When everything seems lost, how
far are you willing to go for
someone you couldn't save?
What's the price you're willing
to pay?
So where do we find our heroes
in all this?
Well, they're hiding.
The three of them are fugitives,
crammed into the forgotten
cellar of some old house,
trapped in a city that
absolutely wants them dead.
So let's get to know the folks
at the center of this mess.
Our fugitives are Yuri Horn, a
beastmaster, Radley, a knight
who wields magic and Dare Men, a
very cunning trickster.
Their only help comes from the
Marta Cobs, who have a pretty
big secret of their own.
Their were Ravens, a race of
shape shifters, and their
situation is just awful.
Bradley and Dermont are still
out of it, recovering from
getting knocked unconscious
during that field rescue.
And all the while your Horn and
his Panther are the only ones
awake, standing guard, just
listening to the sounds of
search parties sweeping the town
for them.
And the danger isn't far away.
It is literally right at their
doorstep.
A search party comes by and the
sound is just terrifying.
They bang on doors to rouse the
inhabitants.
The door to the house the party
is hiding in is rattled.
Can you imagine that tension
hiding in the dark, knowing that
just one wrong sound could give
you away?
They finally managed to sneak
out of that cellar in the early
morning and get back to their
safe house, the Blue Water Inn.
But any relief they feel just
evaporates when they get some
devastating news.
Their friend tracks the door,
the one they tried and failed to
save.
He's been executed, and as a
public statement, the new leader
has had his body hung in the
town square for everyone to see.
It's a message.
But even in all this darkness,
there's this tiny sliver of
hope.
See, they know about a powerful
being called the Abbot.
Turns out he's a celestial, a
creature of immense good.
And the rumors say he can
perform miracles, maybe even
bringing the dead back to life.
And that little bit of hope sets
a crazy plan into motion.
It's basically a high stakes
heist to steal a body and save a
soul.
First they got to scout the
gates and get a cart ready.
Then the really hard part?
Lure the guards away, take them
out, cut down Tracidor's body,
and get out of the city before
anyone realizes what happened.
It's a total long shot, but it's
the only one they've got.
So with this desperate plan in
place, the party slips out under
the cover of night.
They make their way to the
square where their friend's body
is hanging, a grim reminder of
their failure.
And you've got to understand,
this isn't just any Old Town
square.
This place is soaked in tragedy,
and all of it is recent.
Eight days ago, an apparition of
another friend appeared hanging
right here.
A day later, that same friend
was beheaded on this spot.
A few days ago, the town's old
ruler was hung by a mob here.
And now Tracodor's Dottie is
just the latest horror.
OK, so Derriman and Radley kick
the plan off.
They stumble into the square,
acting like a couple of loud
drunks breaking curfew.
And just like they hoped, the
guards, probably bored out of
their minds, take the bait.
And the second the guards get
close, the trap is sprung.
The first guard doesn't even see
it coming.
Derriman's blade finds its mark,
a silent, deadly start to their
ambush.
At the same time, Yurihorn opens
up from a rooftop, raining
arrows down on the other guards,
who are now totally panicking.
The element of surprise is
completely on their side.
The fight is over almost as soon
as it begins.
It's brutal, fast, and
completely merciless.
Your horn's bow takes down 1,
and Radley's fire magic just
horribly incinerates the last
one.
And then the square falls
silent.
With the guards dead, they're
ready to get the body.
For a second, they think they've
actually pulled it off.
But as that silence settles,
they get this chilling feeling
that they didn't spring a trap.
They walked right into one.
And that's when their victory
just curdles into terror.
A new sound echoes across the
square.
It's not more guards, it's cruel
laughter booming across the
square.
Their real enemy has just shown
her hand.
The new Burgo Mistress Lady
walked her appears right in
front of them.
But when Derrman and Eurohorn
attack her, their weapons slice
right through thin air.
It's an illusion, a magical
trick, and you know what that
means.
The real lady walked her has to
be nearby, watching everything
unfold.
But she is not the real threat
here.
Suddenly the air starts to
ripple and out of nowhere these
hellish creatures just appear.
Small batwing devils start
screeching.
A huge man sized beast covered
in wicked barbs lurches forward.
The whole square starts to smell
like brimstone.
These aren't just monsters, they
are devils summoned straight
from the 9 Hells.
So yeah, the plan is shattered.
The heist is over.
Now.
This is just about survival.
It's become a desperate race to
get out of there alive.
And this is where things get
even worse.
Radley launches a fire bolt, the
same spell that just incinerated
a guard, But against these
things, it does absolutely
nothing.
I mean, they're from the 9
Hells.
It's literally a burning
hellscape.
You can't fight them with fire.
In one last desperate move,
Radley just sprints forward,
cuts the rope, and throws
Truxidor's body over his
shoulder.
The whole party just bolts,
trying to heal each other on the
run as Hellfire and spines rain
down on them.
They're racing for the inn, but
they know it's not safe anymore,
not with these things on their
tail.
Which leaves us with this one
chilling question.
They've got their friend's body,
but they're wounded, they're
completely outmatched, and
they're being hunted by actual
devils.
When you're only safe, place is
miles away and the forces of
hell are right behind you, how
do you possibly outrun it?